we recently completed a writing seminar
on food policy a subject that many
people take for granted we've learned
about the farm bill sustainability food
insecurity the politics of eating
organic and the reality behind cheap
food and we'd like to share these
insights with the Yale community so we
gathered a pano three renowned experts
milena Shannon DiPietro director of the
Yale sustainable food project Marlene
Schwartz deputy director of the run
Center for Food Policy and obesity an
errand warsu executive director of City
seed we discussed current food policy
issues in hopes of not only informing
but helping others faster than own
opinions on this controversial issue and
now we'd like to share this with you and
we hope you enjoy um good afternoon and
welcome to English one for teens panel
on food policy before we start the event
will have a little introduction on the
current food policy in America Food
Policy the emphasis of our studies over
the course of the semester has been
plagued with mismanagement mismanagement
and excess promoting a culture in which
every unit of production is valued more
than the health of the American people
the farm bill the main piece of
legislation in American food and
agricultural policy has promoted
environmental awareness but has been
largely ineffective in promoting
healthier eating habits among the
American people the increasing rates of
both diabetes and obesity around the
country are indicative of cultural
excess in which farmers in which farmers
are encouraged to produce as much as
their land will yield as opposed to a
responsible amount to provide for the
American people however there is hope
for the american food system biofuels
and production controls are on the
horizon and inspire hope for the state
of the american food system with
adjustments made to the farm bill the
american food and agricultural policy
may be able to cure food-related
illnesses and promote a healthier
society with that being said we have
invited three distinguished guests to
speak to us about a variety of issues
pertaining to food policy and the
American agricultural system the first
is miss Aaron woopsy it and she is the
executive director of CDC and
organization involved with
markets in and around New Haven
providing food at affordable prices for
people of all socioeconomic backgrounds
their mission incorporates the promotion
of farmers markets around the area as
well as making the goods available to
all people her expertise includes the
foundation of farmers markets and other
projects as well as granting and funding
ideas that pertain to City seed our next
panelist is Marlene Schwartz while in
Schwartz is the deputy director of the
red Center her area of interest is the
impact is the impact home environments
communities and school landscapes have
on the eating attitudes and behaviors of
children the red Center at Yale works to
inform the public about policies related
to nutrition and obesity they work to
combat obesity by advocating change in
policies regarding the expansion and
advertising of non healthy food markets
a few weeks ago shorts and some of her
colleagues at the Rudd Center published
a study addressing the fact that the
most heavily marketed serious for
children are the least healthy through
numerous studies and research like this
shorts and her colleagues reached reach
the public with vital information about
health and nutrition the next panelist
is Melina Shannon DiPietro and she is a
director of the Yale sustainable food
project or the why why sfp around yield
she's also known as the Dean of food
over her years at Yale she has worked
closely with the dining services in the
transition to a sustainable seasonable
menu she also oversees the Yale farm a
why sfp initiative that encourages
sustainable farming and supplies
Connecticut farmers markets as well as
local restaurants as director of the why
sfp miss miss Shannon DiPietro is
working towards spreading awareness to
the Yale community about food
agriculture and environment thank you
for coming so we're going to start off
by asking our experts a question that a
general question so with each of you
tell us about your professional
background and how you got into this
field and your present position and was
there an ah-ha moment for
view um well so I just started at City
seed in July actually and before that
was getting my MBA at Yale and really
came out of nonprofit management
specifically to go get an MBA and be
able to take the the quantitative skills
that you get in a business degree and
use them to help nonprofits be more
effective be more efficient be able to
reach more people and and in the middle
of my business degree and i will say for
anyone who's looking to do a business
degree Yale has a great one and one of
the things that they really promote is
thinking about what do you care about
what do you love what changes do you
want to see in society and and take your
business skills and go affect those
changes so I was interested in food
before i came to business school but i
actually worked in other nonprofits
non-food related nonprofits before i
came here and in the course of my study
realized i love to eat and that's kind
of i love to cook I love to eat I love
to eat with people and and what better
way to to to use that love to to think
about how does society think about
eating and and local food just kind of
naturally for me came out of that so I
interned at City seed in between my
first and second year of business school
and and realized that it was something
that I it was an organization I really
cared about and so when the opportunity
came up to stay and work for them for a
little bit I I took I took it and I can
I'll talk more about City seed but but
that's kind of how I came at this well
my background actually is as a clinical
psychologist I got my PhD in clinical
psychology here at Yale and my training
was sort of general psychology but
strength of our program was eating
disorders and obesity and so I started
off after I graduated as co-director of
the Yale Center for eating and weight
disorders and so I did clinical work
with both children and adolescents and
adults addressing the whole spectrum
from anorexia bulimia binge eating
disorder and obesity and I well I love
doing clinical work I often felt like I
would be sitting with someone in my
office for an hour a week and you know
we focus on behavior change and what you
know the person could do and then it was
as if they went out into the world and
the world completely undid all the hard
work that we had just accomplished in my
office and so I became much more
interested in how to change what was
going on outside so that it would
instead of conflicting with what we were
trying to teach people to do what
actually reinforce it and then when my
own children started school and I saw
even in you know kindergarten first
grade that the food the foods that were
being sold in the schools were again
completely in conflict with what I was
trying to teach my own children that's
when I really decided to shift my focus
entirely to research especially research
of the food environment surrounding kids
so an aha moment i had was when my
daughter anna started first grade and
they were selling sort of ice cream and
potato chips and in all kinds of stuff
every single day and she wanted money to
buy that and we sort of compromise and
said she could you know buy something
once a week and I was trying to pace
myself I didn't wanna go marching into
the principal's office you know like the
third day of my child's you know school
year and I was okay until probably about
you know the last week of sep tember
when we got a notice saying that the PTO
was holding a cookie eating contest as a
fundraiser and I actually called my boss
Kelly Brownell on the phone and said
this is this is crazy what am I going to
do and so I called the principal and
that actually was what set in motion our
districts starting a health advisory
committee which is still in existence
today and we still have changes to make
but we've come a pretty long way so it
was really that sort of combination of
my you know sort of scientific and
research knowledge
with again this very sort of present and
important thing to me meaning my
children's environment and having those
come together that led to my interest in
this so Marlene story has just reminded
me that in kindergarten I was the child
whose parents refused to bring in
cookies or munchkins and instead brought
in ants on a log to celery with peanut
butter and raisins you know these which
is terribly embarrassing when I was five
but sure Shirley says something about my
later career um so my background is in
teaching and in farming and actually a
bit in business I spent two years as a
consultant straight out of undergraduate
work and well before that my family had
had a huge backyard garden was visiting
farms it's pretty standard practice that
in June my mom would pull me out of
school so we could go strawberry picking
and we would strawberry pick all day
long and bring strawberries home and
freeze them so we would have them to eat
for the winter or make jam with them but
the ha ha moment for me but there were a
couple of times the first one was a very
personal one I was working at this
consulting firm loved the skills I was
learning all the all these great
quantitative skills and methods of
analysis and ways of working with people
and organizations to change those
organizations but it was like ten thirty
at night I was sitting at a gray desk in
a gray room eating takeout sushi from
like a gray Styrofoam container and I
thought this is no fun like this is not
the way I want to eat dinner at night um
so there was that moment and then the
more important moment came about a month
later I had just returned to my desk we
were volunteering in Boston Public
Schools helping them think about how to
get better test performance um because
school testing was a big issue and a
friend had sent me a three minute video
from Nairobi Kenya where he was and in
that three minute video that was staged
at an aids orphanage the children were
eating and these were these children
primarily had AIDS or had lost their
parents to AIDS but we're eating a diet
that was coloreds millet and some beans
they didn't have enough food but these
were sick children eating really healthy
food which was a stark stark contrast to
what I had just seen in Boston Public
Schools where we had healthy children
eating food that was making them sick
and so it was that contrast that for me
was a defining moment that meant I was
going to spend my life working on this
issue and when the opportunity came up
to help define the sustainable food
project for Yale and help build this
program I jumped at it because I think
there's an incredible community here who
wants to support great food and good
agriculture and sustainability more
largely and that every student goes out
into the world and has the power to be
an errand or Marlene in their home
communities we're going to begin with a
few individual questions the first is
directed toward miss woopsy and in what
ways is city sees ensuring that
nutritious foods are reaching people of
all backgrounds and socio-economic
standing in New Haven um well we have a
couple different programs i will say
just as a preface that city seed has two
goals the first is to support the
viability of farms in the state of
Connecticut and the second is to make
sure that everyone who everyone can
access has has has available to them
healthy local whenever possible food and
and these two things are not always
easily then don't always mesh together
so we're sort of constantly struggling I
think we'll talk a little bit later
about affordability question but but
those are those are our goals and and so
we go along that path so in addition to
the farm viability projects that we do
we also have these food access projects
so the founder of City seed is a yale
college graduate and it was extremely
important to her right off the bat that
that the farmers markets in New Haven
when they started up the one in wooster
square in in 2004
be able to accept food stamps and be
able to accept WIC farmers market
promotion coupons and and that sort of
been a tenant so we sort of started from
that base and we have an amazing
redemption rate on on both of those
things so so over the last five years
we've redeemed over 250 thousand dollars
in WIC and food stamps and then so that
is directly people who who need to
access this food being able to do that
at the farmers markets and primarily
that's fresh fruits and vegetables which
i think is just hugely important and so
so we started out with wooster square
and then and then we added on three
additional farmers markets downtown
fairhaven and an Edgewood Park and fair
haven is I would define it as the most
low income of the farmers markets a
communities where where we have a market
and to be quite honest that farmers
market didn't do very well at the
beginning it it was in this neighborhood
where people really needed to access
fresh local fruits and vegetables
healthy fruits and vegetables but the
people who were there kind of had a cap
on spending and so for us farmers
markets need to they need to be good for
three groups of people they need to be
good for the community they need to be
good for the market goers and they need
to be good for the farmers and our
farmers were saying we really can't
afford to go to this farmers market
we're not making enough money to afford
the gas and the extra person to man it
and so how can you help us we see that
this is important to have here how can
you help us make sure that we make
enough money so we started we started
our version of a community supported
agriculture project it's a
community-supported market and actually
the Red Centre and is one of the
drop-off points for shares to get
delivered to our
side outside of the market to people so
that so if you know the the concept of a
CSA you have people buy shares and they
put up the money upfront and then they
get a farm will deliver to them a box of
produce throughout the season so we
basically did the same thing with the
market but every single one of the
farmers at that market contributes to
the share and the money from that then
goes directly to the farmer so right off
the bat the farmer gets to the farmers
market and has already made enough money
to justify the expense of coming and so
then everything after that is an
additional amount of money that they're
getting so they so so the farmers market
while it took a little bit longer to to
really gel in that neighborhood is now
there and supporting that neighborhood
as a access point for fresh food and
then the second thing we did was because
this delivery of shares of produce was
so was so successful with work sites we
got funding to also deliver subsidized
shares to senior centers and community
centers in places in New Haven where
they don't have access to food there's
there are several several communities in
New Haven that that simply don't have
access to supermarkets or very much food
at all and so we now also deliver shares
to to those places and a lot of the
people that we're delivering to they use
their three dollar farmers market
promotion program coupon to to to access
that food so a question from this
DiPietro it's sustainable farming able
to support the US food system given the
recent economic downturn how does ZL
dining compromise between price and
sustainability I'm going to take that as
two questions because there's a lot
there I think I might flip that question
on its head the first question and ask
whether the u.s. is ready to support
sustainable farming so it turns out a
third of our greenhouse gas emissions
are related to food and as I'm sure you
know from your class that one in three
children born in two thousand
will be diagnosed with type 2 diabetes
and Michelle Obama is actually out there
reminding us regularly right now that
this generation of children is the first
generation of children that's likely to
die before their parents or have a have
a shorter life than their parents and so
I think we need to support sustainable
farming it leads to a healthy healthier
land right it can cut down on greenhouse
gas emissions it can help bring produce
to the table that I think tastes better
over and over again and often has higher
nutrient values and so it can help us
tackle some of the biggest problems in
the nation the other thing that I think
is really critical in this particular
time is that regional food systems so
the type of food systems that city seat
is building or that Yale has built to
support its sustainable dining program
can actually build jobs and it builds
jobs close to home whether those are
farming jobs or producer jobs or
processing jobs and I think we have to
take a moment and figure out a way to
support sustainable farming there are a
number of ways to do that the farm bill
is a huge one USDA has released new
grants and packaged old grants so that
you can now explore those opportunities
online and I think institutions like
schools hospitals museums are great
centers to think about how to change
their purchasing and have a
community-wide effect so that's I think
we need to support it as a nation if
we're going to build a healthy nation
and then I think the second part how
Yale faces this dilemma it's a huge
challenge when we started building the
sustainable food project one thing we
were really clear on was wanting to
build a program that would be replicable
so that it wouldn't just be the
Harvard's and Yale's of the world that
could have sustainable food in their
dining halls but this program could be a
model for New Haven public schools or
for state colleges or the like and so
we've tried very carefully to create
menus that are affordable across the
board and it means brokering interesting
purchasing deals it means sometimes
decreasing variety on the menu but we
learned that
is okay when you provide really good
food students actually don't mind if
there's less variety because they have
three great options rather than five
mediocre options and then the third
thing is constant compromise and
juggling so maybe you serve a little bit
less meat so that you can have really
awesome grass-fed beef burgers but I
think in much the same way that we all
make these choices and do a little bit
of juggling at home Yale does it in its
dining halls miss Schwartz in response
to your sorry in response to your recent
blog article good foods bad foods and
non foods would you be in favor of the
government cutting the option for food
stamp recipients to buy non foods or do
you believe in consumer freedom of
choice so so this was a blog where
there's a big debate about whether there
are good foods and bad foods and a lot
of the like you official position of the
American Dietetic Association and the
USDA and every food company out there is
that there are no good foods and bad
foods which of course means it that none
of their foods can be considered bad so
what I learned though is because this
came up because of the idea of taxing
soft drinks is are there some foods that
really shouldn't even count as foods and
I actually found out in the state of
Connecticut that soft drinks and some
other categories don't even count as
food so you do pay sales tax on those
whereas you don't pay sales tax on
regular foods so in terms of what that
means for food stamps you know I tend to
think about you know the role of
government is really to promote the
healthiest behaviors to promote the
healthiest products and if the idea of
the food stamp program which is supposed
to be a supplemental nutrition program
that if they're individuals that don't
have enough money to buy food then I
think that the food that they are given
this money to purchase should be
supplemental nutrition with the emphasis
on the word nutrition so personally I
would argue that if something provides
no nutritious value like soft drinks
that it doesn't make sense for us to be
encouraging that that
no this is government funding and it you
know we could argue that this money
should be used to buy the healthiest of
the foods not the least healthy with
that said it's a tough argument to make
because 1 i'd say challenge in the food
policy world is that you have people and
i would consider myself one of them that
are mostly focused on obesity and type 2
diabetes and health consequences and
then you have this whole other group of
advocates and researchers who are
focused on food insecurity and hunger
and they've actually been around a lot
longer than we have because the problems
been around a lot longer and I feel like
we're just starting to really figure out
how to work together and one way to
really i'd say mess up that relationship
is to start talking about setting limits
on food stamps so you know my personal
opinion and obviously you know this is
what I would you know sort of say
philosophically is that we should set
limits but I don't feel like as a field
we are ready for that kind of policy so
it's not what I would choose as my first
battle beginning with the general
questions for all three of our panelists
like we'd like to ask is eating right
solely a personal choice or shoot food
industries and the government be
responsible as well also how can the
government help people make the right
food choices well I think the government
helps us decide what to eat every single
day and so its bigger than it being a
personal choice um here at yale yale
dining helps decide what you eat every
single day right so often this is
legislated or encouraged in particular
directions and when I think about the
most vulnerable populations in the US
children there's 30 million children who
are eating school lunch in our nation's
schools are public schools and I think
there is a great place to start when we
think about providing really good
healthy food to people i think we've
sort of confused the language of
personal responsibility and independence
for a language about
what's healthy and the type of behavior
and culture we want to encourage as a
society and so I think we need really
big policy support that helps put the
right incentives in place encourages
healthy behaviors as Marlene was saying
and then on individual and cultural and
family levels want to encourage cooking
at home sharing meals together and
making sure that foods healthy when you
do
so that phase how does one bridge the
gap between public opinion and policy
regarding food I think it's not that
well it's a really good question I can
tell you what we're trying to do at the
red Center and I don't know if we can
say it's successful but basically what
we focus on is what we term strategic
science so the idea is that you do
research studies that are you know
rigorous empirical studies to you know
sort of illustrate an issue so for
example like you mentioned the serial
study that just came out so we you know
got several million dollars from the
Robert Wood Johnson Foundation to do
with this huge project where we purchase
nielsen data and other types of
syndicated advertising data so that we
could prove beyond a doubt that the
cereal companies are taking their least
healthy cereals and those are the ones
where they're putting all their money
and to market them to children so in
doing that study we then were able to
get a lot of media attention so Kelly
was on Good Morning America and world
news tonight and you know a bunch of
other things like that and that I think
is then what's going to change public
opinion so the sort of mechanism through
which I think public opinion can shift
is basically doing science to prove that
you know a there's a problem and be when
we can what some of the solutions might
be and then the media has a huge role to
play because it's they're really letting
the public know about this research that
I think will eventually shift people's
opinions
so slightly more personal question just
in terms of your food choices um what do
you all by at shop at the at the market
and what do you look for I'm happy to
take this um so I I have to say I am I
really shop at the farmers market almost
exclusively at this point I'm partly
because my husband and I just this year
put our first gardenin and our carrots
were that big so we didn't really
produce too much food out of that um but
but partly because I know exactly where
my food is coming from and what
practices were used to grow it and i
know i typically know the person who's
grown it which i think is amazing and I
know what I know how much more of my
dollar is going to support a farmer then
is going to support a very very long
chain of distributors and buyers and
suppliers and and i'm potentially
ultimately a farmer way back but i don't
know if that farmer is a five acre farm
who's using sustainable practices or a
twenty-five hundred acre farm that's
using that's using spraying
indiscriminately so and I actually I'm
not a vegetarian and I'm I enjoy the
grass-fed cheeseburger every once in a
while and so but I've found that as I
eat at the farmer's markets almost
exclusively I eat less meat and more
fruits and vegetables and part of it is
because the meat is more expensive but I
know that the reasons it's more
expensive is because it's produced in a
way that I'm more comfortable with so I
I've used that trade-off to eat less
meat and more fruits and vegetables but
to get better quality stuff when I am
buying
oh I'll add a little bit to that um I a
lot like Aaron and I feel very lucky
that I can shop at farmer's market or
grow the food I eat and I would say like
this is not a perfect system right I
can't grow the coffee that I'm going to
drink in the morning or the tea and I
have a real weakness for chocolate and
so when I'm eating those things I make
sure that they come from a source I
trust and that means third-party
certification I think that third-party
certification that it's organic and fair
trade is so important when you can't
know the farmer or visit their fields
and so that's that's another thing I
look for another thing I'll say is I've
been traveling a lot and grocery shopped
recently in Washington DC in a pretty
upscale neighborhood where there was a
generic grocery store and then one of
those other grocery stores that sort of
made its reputation on serve and selling
you know organic foods and the protis in
these stars both of them was junk um
it's nothing like what you have at
farmer's market and I just think we
would we would all eat more fruits and
vegetables if we went to farmers market
more regularly how can food or health
organizations and individual collaborate
to bring about change in the food
industry well you know I I like the
advice I think it was the end of the
movie food inc where they basically said
you get to vote three times a day as you
make a decision you know I also do my
best to to buy organic food and to you
know during when we participate in the
CSM in the summertime and so I think
those decisions help and the more people
that feel like their little individual
decisions like a difference I think
something that's hard is people you know
most people feel like what they do
themselves is not going to have an
impact on Kellogg's or on your some
giant company but I think the more that
consumers can learn that in the end they
the most powerful group really I mean we
we did a study in new haven where we
went into small markets across New Haven
little stores and ask them about why
they do or don't stock various healthier
options and across the board they said
if our customers wanted it we would we
would stock it and so I think that you
know really teaching consumers that it's
okay to ask for your store to stock
something and that those things over
time really will make a difference and
frankly I think they have I mean I think
that you know the culture has changed in
the last ten years and people are
demanding more organic food and knowing
where their food is from so I would say
that that's probably one of the most
effective ways to do that individuals
get your Congress people to work for you
I think that the work that City seed and
the run Center have done on the policy
level are huge but up coming this spring
there's the child nutrition
reauthorization act wherever you live
ask your Congress people to support
increased funding for school lunch and
for mandatory farm to school funding
that type of policy change will give us
the resources to support these
individual changes also add that I think
what the red sinners doing is is really
helping the rest of us because i love
the strategic science phrase i think
it's great because we have the
philosophy behind why you eat locally
and why you eat sustainably and why you
why you should care how much of your
dollar goes where but but being able to
then support it with with the studies is
really really helpful when we go and
talk to our Congress people and and go
and talk to consumers about about eating
in this manner what's being done in New
Haven to promote healthy eating and a
healthy lifestyle how are how are you
guys getting the word out I'm happy cuz
I mean a lot is the answer actually um
first of all they're just a lot of
organizations that are working on this
issue and actually the city of New Haven
just submitted a grant to the the CDC to
get funding
to do a big project that is specifically
trying to get people to eat healthier
and an exercise more and and I was
amazed at how many groups came around
the table specifically to apply for that
grant we're actually I think one of the
things that I didn't get a chance to say
before is that it's great to have access
to fresh fruits and vegetables but if
you don't know how to cook them or you
don't feel comfortable cooking them that
that that that also makes it difficult
for you to consume these these healthier
foods and so one of the things that we
are in the in the process of creating is
a community cookbook that is scheduled
to come out later this month and and
it's specifically supposed to be easier
recipes using fruits and vegetables from
the farmers markets you know along with
other things that you can get a group at
your grocery store and and they're all
from New Haven residents and there is
one from the L sustainable food project
and there's a recipe from the New Haven
public school district and and we're
hoping that that's going to be something
that rallies people are around healthier
eating so I know you're doing a lot of
things yeah I mean there's there's a
fair amount of both research and I think
sort of community involvement in a
project called care which is being run
by a woman named genetic effects who's
in the School of Public Health and so
that's a pretty comprehensive program
where they're really focusing on smoking
actually as one thing but also nutrition
and physical activity and they're
working in the school's trying to do
some data collection to find out what
sorts of eating and activity levels the
kids are at now and then I'm tracking
that over time so there is a fair amount
going on in terms of research in New
Haven something that we studied recently
was the loss of biodiversity and the
development of a monoculture so what are
your thoughts on generally genetically
modified foods
um well i think it's a it's a tricky
question um I think like most of the
like most of the questions that people
want to know the answers to in in local
food it's just so much more complicated
than then the initial question would
ever intimate so my preference my
preference is for hybridization instead
of of GMO genetically modified partly
because that's how we've been deciding
on crops for since agriculture was
started so so a lot of the crops we have
right right now we're not we're not what
people cultivated thousands of years ago
but we realized oh well this is a better
crop for us we can we can grow it better
and that's worked for us and but there
are places where it's more difficult to
grow crops even if you're growing and
not in a monoculture and then it's a
little bit more difficult because you
don't you're you're you're weighing
people getting food versus the
environment versus the sort of the
science of it also i would say it is
akin to the public health versus food
access not vs. but but this these sort
of different goals of different
organizations and and finding the
solution that works for everyone is is
tough and i think that's one of the
things that we're trying to work on but
but monoculture is i think something
that we could do without we just need to
figure out the way to get there
if you could change one aspect of the
food industry and one aspect only what
would it be of the whole
one um well one one thing that I get
really frustrated with with the food
industry because it is so big it's so
complicated is that any time like we do
a study on a particular segment whether
it's soft drinks or cereals or fast food
the people representing that industry
come back and say yes but it's not only
us you know we are not you know you know
sugared cereals are not responsible for
the childhood obesity epidemic or soft
drinks aren't responsible and they
should maybe make these pie charts where
they show like added sugar and
children's diets and you know the
general mills one emphasizes all the
sugar they get from soda and then the
Pepsi one emphasizes all the sugar they
get from cereals and everybody's always
sort of Plenty fingers so if I could
change one thing I would try to change
that attitude from what psychologists
called diffusion of responsibility where
everybody sort of thinks everybody else
is responsible to everyone saying okay
what can we do and sort of taking
responsibility and to rather than you
know we've got this incredibly
competitive system where you know sort
of easy for us to say you know coke and
pepsi and Dr Pepper should all you know
kind of simultaneously decrease the
sugar or so that you know people can get
used to less sugary drinks but we forget
they're all competitors with each other
and so I guess to to find a way so that
the industry could actually work more in
concert as a group for the good of
public health rather than constantly
pointing fingers and fighting with each
other and using their competition as an
excuse not to take risks to change their
product would be good one that's not too
much um I you know I'm gonna I'm going
to go on them on the farm side here and
we didn't really talk about the
affordability of food but um you know
it's traditionally farmers markets have
been touted as being an expensive place
to get your food and i would say that
there are lots of good reasons why that
may be the case but I think for me and
this partly I think is my business my
business education is I wish that there
was an easy way to include in the price
of all food the externalities the things
that you don't pay for immediately the
the fact that health care is extremely
expensive in our country right now the
fact that we are losing farmland at a
very scary rate and what does that do to
our rural communities in the fabric of
life in those places and and and that's
something I think that were we're
getting towards but it's not an easy oh
we're just going to slap a premium on it
and that'll take care of of how what
you're not currently paying for the
fossil fuels to ship tomatoes from
California the fossil fuels to make the
GMO crop in order to to have those
Tomatoes so um that would be that would
be lovely so one last question for both
of you what's your view on the
soft-drink text I just got implemented
and what would you say to someone who
claims that the government is trying to
control what we eat well actually there
isn't a yeah you may think that because
we talk about it so much and no no it
hasn't been implemented anywhere no so
by boss Kelly Brownell he's been talking
about wanting there to be a soft drink
tax and it has yet to be implemented
anywhere the closest thing is some
states have what they call you know
either snack taxes or things like that
but these have typically been very small
taxes a lot of them have been recalled
after a few years and the money has just
sort of gone into a general fund but the
type of soft drink text that that the
red Center talks about has been
discussed in California and New York and
a few other places but hasn't actually
been implemented anywhere I think you
know
it's I think it's something that maybe
people still aren't quite ready for but
as those of us have been around for a
while know that when Kelly first started
talking about this idea back in 1995
nobody took it seriously at all and now
the fact that it's even getting
discussed quite seriously in the new
england journal of medicine is
publishing papers on it shows that we've
come a long way but i think that the
only way it's really going to work is if
people really trust and believe that
that money is going towards something
good like people don't like the idea of
attacks just so that the government has
more money to do whatever it does
because people don't trust the
government to spend the money wisely but
if that tax were for example went
specifically to bring down the price of
produce that's you know raised in a
sustainable way or something that people
really feel is you know an important
part of our food system that needs extra
income then I think people would
probably be more supportive you think
that tax if it were implemented in any
of the states you mentioned what do you
think it'd be effective well effective
at what I mean urban soft drink well we
have done research looking at price
elasticity and looking at you know
there's a lot of I mean it I'm not an
economist so I sort of have to just take
the word of the economist that do this
work but there is you know if you
increase the cost of something people do
tend to switch their options so if you
only increase the cost of
sugar-sweetened beverages and low sugar
or non sugared beverages stay the same a
certain percentage of people really are
going to start switching to the lower
sugar beverages so I think it would work
in terms of shifting people's drinking
patterns and what Kelly says is you know
the best evidence that this is going to
change consumption is the fact that Coke
and Pepsi are spending unbelievable
amounts of money lobbying against this
so if they didn't actually think this
would work they wouldn't be wasting
their time in their lobbying money but
they've I can't remember the exact
number but hundreds of thousands of
dollars are being spent to lobby against
it so there must be you know there must
be a way that that they feel like this
is
right please correct me this hadn't been
your experience but it's been mine that
there's sortable news I guess
specifically when it comes to matters of
sustainable food and food justice and
it's even more specifically farmers
markets there's something there like
there are a socio-economic stigma both
from one from people not wanting to be
seen patronizing farmers markets with
wicker with food stamps errs and the
other from sort of a broader cultural
perception of farmers markets and those
that those issues of being I guess
exclusively the province of
well-educated well-off people who have
the time and money and luxury did I
guess take care of those issues so I
guess in terms of broadening the reach
of farmers markets broadening the
coalition that supports them and how do
you change that culture um it's tough um
I think that in I'll take that the
second question I think first which is
um I think in the past it has definitely
been true that farmers markets have have
attracted a certain type of a person of
a certain income level which i think is
really unfortunate it's so very
state-by-state farmers markets so
Connecticut has a Connecticut has a very
a very hard time with farmland because
because of the the size of the state
because of the rate of farmland lost and
so consequently it's the price points
are not always what we would want to see
them be at the farmers market what we do
is we we spend a lot of time making sure
that our farmers markets represent a
diversity not only of products
and farmers brought of price points and
some of the larger farms are able to get
their prices down a little bit farther
than some of the smaller farms and and
and actually that's not even across the
board true what we so we've been seeing
a growing growing our diversity has been
growing over the last five years and I
think that that's only going to become
more so I also think that places like
Yale and the New Haven public school
district are doing a great job of
getting this type of food into the hands
of people and in other ways and I think
that that's part of what we need to do
in Connecticut you shouldn't only have
to go to a farmers market to get good
healthy local food you should be able to
go to the grocery store and still make
sure that you know what's going on with
your food you had a second question I
guess follow up on that last comment so
maybe the strategies to make healthy
local sustainable food not just
something that can be found in this one
specific Enclave and the certain day of
the week but more something that's the
BIC witness or you know people eat
anywhere to get their food yeah I'm
right now i think it's it's really it's
tough we we don't have the we don't have
the farms in Connecticut right now to to
fully stock all of the supermarkets in
the state that is that's absolutely the
case but I think that there are other
reasons to have farms in Connecticut
other than fully stocking the stop and
shop so there was another question you
asked I wanted oh the the WIC and ABT um
so we have a system actually where you
come to the farmers market with your
food stamps and you come to the farm the
table the city seed table and you get
coins and you can get coins from using
your debit card or your credit card or
you can get coins from using your EBT
which is the foods the way that you get
food stamps and I think that that goes a
long way to do it to help help
with this and so that's why we've seen
an increase every year in our and our
redemption of ABT wick i think is a
little bit more difficult because they
still get they still get coupons but
we're doing we're trying to move in that
direction absolutely thank you thank you
very much this one's for dr. Schwartz I
know you talk a lot about the nutrition
and in schools I wanted to know I wrote
a paper like what about exercise and
what what role do you think that plays
into this whole obesity epidemic and
what what should be that I don't know if
that falls in the area ashford is great
can certainly try to answer that
question so this comes up a lot because
everybody knows that you know weight is
determined by calories in calories out
and calories out if you want to increase
it the best way is to do more physical
activity the best way like when I was
treating obesity as a clinician we
certainly encourage patients to increase
their exercise exercise and decrease
their calories the research though is
quite clear that if somebody wants to
lose weight it's much more effective to
focus on the calories in part of the
equation then the calories out and that
it's very hard to lose weight if you
keep your intake the same and you just
exercise whereas you can lose weight if
you decrease your calories and you keep
your activity level the same and part of
that as those of you who've ever paid
attention to how many calories you burn
you know it can take a long time if I'm
on my treadmill which tells me calories
and I want to go up to 300 calories that
that takes me a while to get to 300
calories on the treadmill but you can
eat 300 calories in about five minutes
so if it's you know can deer or
something like that or you know three
quarters of a Big Mac so I think that um
when it comes to obesity there's really
no question that it's more important
food intake now with that said there are
a lot of benefits of physical activity
that have nothing to do with weight loss
that once people lose weight the best
predictor of them keeping that weight
off is very high levels of physical
activity like on the order
of you know an hour a day of physical
activity those people will be much more
successful in keeping their weight off
than people who don't do that and in
addition to the weight effect it's
simply healthier to be more physically
active so I'm a huge proponent of
increasing physical activity in schools
for kids and you know sometimes it's
hard during the school day because
there's so much they're trying to pack
in but having you know lots of
afterschool programs or other
opportunities for kids to be active i
think is you know definitely a good
thing and not watching television and
you know sedentary things but if you're
really concerned about childhood obesity
and you can only you know you have
limited resources in order to effect
change you're going to get more change
focusing on food than on PE well we
would like to thank those who made this
panel possible the panelists ms Schwartz
miss woopsy and miss Shannon DiPietro
the tech people who put this together
Robin professor Stewart the people at
itg CM I to the collaborative learning
center and finally those in trumbull
college and the tremolo dining commons
for opening their space to us thank you
all good night